the night sky is spangled with countless
stars
some of them are so staggeringly far
that it would have taken the light from
some of them thousands of years to reach
the earth
others are comparatively close to us by
space standards
i've already told you about a few stars
closest to our system in our previous
videos but there are other exciting
objects among the immediate neighbors of
our sun
let's make our acquaintance with some of
them
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
there are approximately 1
400 stellar systems in space within the
radius of 50 light years from the solar
system
some of them are multiple and contain
two and more objects which makes the
overall number of our stellar neighbors
over two thousand
these are all sorts of stars from dim
red dwarves to dazzling giants whose
temperatures are beyond our imagination
the incredible scale and great abundance
of space objects and all their diversity
can't but amaze
life's too short to give account of each
and every one of them
right now we're going to travel at
incredible speeds by far faster than the
speed of light
it will take us just a few minutes to
cover dozens of light years of space
we'll get to check out quite a few
remarkable space objects around the
solar system
other worlds and stars are already
waiting
after we fly round proxima centauri a
detour of 11 light years that would have
passed in the blink of an eye we're in
the environs of the dim red dwarf known
as ros 128
we can't see it from the earth with a
naked eye on pre-possessing though it
may seem there is an earth-like
exoplanet dubbed ros128b orbiting this
star
this exoplanet is one of the closest to
us
unlike the yet closer and cooler proxima
centauri b
the temperature on dros 128b is
relatively moderate ranging from -60 to
plus 21 degrees celsius
assuming its surface to be identical to
that of our planet which absorbs 70
percent of the light shed on it the
equilibrium temperature of ros 128 b is
estimated at around 7 degrees celsius
it is 8 degrees cooler than that of
today's earth but quite enough to
sustain life the exoplanet's mass is
roughly 35 percent bigger than that of
the earth
the radius hasn't been accurately
measured at this point
but provided the planet's composition is
similar to our earth's its diameter is
supposed to be roughly 10 percent bigger
than that of the earth the free-fall
acceleration on its surface is expected
to be just 12 percent bigger than that
on our planet
if all these estimations are correct
then the conditions on the surface of
rospan 28b are supposed to be comparable
with those on the earth
besides the system is rapidly moving to
meet the sun
in just 79 000 years it will be closer
to us than proxima centauri which is
moving away from us
quite like most exoplanets we know of
ros 128b is located quite close to its
host star
the distance from it to the center of
the system is just 0.05 astronomical
units or 20 times shorter than the
distance between the earth and the sun
it takes the exoplanet slightly under 10
days to complete a full orbit around its
star
it is also thought that it must be
tidally
locked speaking about its host star ros
128 its mass is approximately 17 percent
that of the sun with the radius
measuring around 0.2 that of the sun
the star's surface temperature is twice
as low as out of the sun
at
3192 kelvin and its luminosity is
roughly 300 times lower than that of the
sun it's worth mentioning that dros 128
is a comparatively quiet star
with its luminosity quite stable and
regular it hardly ever flares up or
emits stellar matter so pernicious for
all living things
moving on through space 12 light years
in the direction pointing away from the
sun we will see light and star also
known as gj273
it boasts one of the largest planetary
systems detected in the space nearest to
us
the star itself is a red dwarf of an
orange hue whose mass is just 25 that of
the sun
its radius is three times smaller than
that of the sun and its luminosity is
435 times lower so it's hardly
surprising that it can only be seen
through a telescope
it is quite an exciting star because
there are as many as four objects
detected in its environs two of which
are confirmed exoplanets
the other two are still prospective
candidates awaiting confirmation the
first confirmed exoplanet was dubbed
light and b it was detected thanks to
high precision measurement of the star's
proper motion the object's mass is
estimated to be about 2.89 times that of
the earth its radius is 35 percent
bigger than that of our planet this
makes the object a super earth and its
surface gravity may turn out to be
suitable for humans
the distance between the system's center
and light and b equals roughly 0.1
astronomical units although the amount
of light received by the exoplanet from
its parent star is comparable with that
received by us from the sun
thus light and b lies in its star's
habitable zone and may well be
considered a potential candidate for
searching for alien life the equilibrium
surface temperature of the planet is 259
to 292 kelvin or minus 14 to plus 19
degrees celsius
this makes the conditions on light and b
quite suitable for humans
the other confirmed exoplanet in the
system is light and sea
with this space object's mass similar to
that of the earth it lies much closer to
its host star the exact parameters of
its orbit haven't been defined yet but
it is known that it takes the object
just 4.7 days to complete a full orbit
around its system's center
it is likely that this is a scorching
hot and harsh celestial body without any
atmosphere with one on the same side
facing the star at all times
the two other objects in the system were
discovered in 2019 and are still
awaiting confirmation of their status
according to preliminary estimates there
are ice giants with masses from 5 to 15
times out of the earth with the radii of
their orbits lying within 0.8
astronomical units their orbital periods
cannot be over
558 days
lighten is a relatively cold star and
with these two objects lying beyond its
habitable zone their temperatures are
almost certainly extremely low
it goes without saying that at this
stage these two candidates still want
further exploration
moving on and away from the lighting
system we will come across a star known
as altair
lying 16.8 light years away from the
earth it is a bright white blue star
its mass is around 1.8 that of the sun
and its age is estimated at around 1.2
billion years
this star's luminosity is 11 times that
of the sun which makes it one of the
most conspicuous objects in our night
sky
another curious feature about air is its
rotation which is remarkably fast
thus it spins on its axis approximately
67 times faster than the sun it
completes a full rotation within
slightly less than 9 hours the velocity
of star material at the equator equals
about
286 kilometers per second due to this
outstandingly rapid rotation the star's
shape is far from an ideal sphere the
star's equatorial diameter is 22 percent
bigger than the distance between its
poles and is roughly twice the diameter
of the sun
the star's shape can't but affect its
temperature and luminosity which also
differ in its different areas
the stellar matter in the equatorial
zone of the star is noticeably colder
and darker than in the poles
the temperature at the equator is just
6900 kelvin
the poles meanwhile are as hot as 8 500
kelvin which is around 8
200 degrees celsius
interestingly the fact that altair has
an irregular shape was first arrived at
following theoretical calculations
only later in 2007 was it finally
confirmed after an image of the star was
produced where it is seen to have a
disc-like shape
actually altair happened to become the
first star beyond the solar system whose
surface had been imaged
unfortunately no planet has been
detected in altair's environs still
observations show rings or a fog of gas
enveloping the star
altair's light is dispersed in these
structures which produces a curious
effect
this major interference of light results
in a humongous rainbow around the star
on the downside however even though it
looks fascinating and majestic it partly
conceals this style and so greatly
hampers studying it
as we carry on on our way through space
we will get as far as thermal health
lying 25 light years away from the earth
this stellar system consists of three
components for a long time the three
components making it up used to be
considered mutually independent space
objects
then in 2013 evidence showed that they
are in fact gravitationally bound
forming a large and single structure in
space
thermal howd is probably the widest
multiple star system located close to
ours the biggest distance between its
components reaches 3.2 light years
incidentally almost 11 lunar discs may
be placed in our night sky between the
remotest objects in the thermal health
system
the largest most well-known and
well-seen component of the system is
referred to as thermal health a
it's a young and hot star whose mass is
92 percent bigger than that of the sun
with its radius measuring around 1.85
times that of the sun
it was this star that people have
referred to as thermal health since
ancient times
quite unaware of the fact that there are
other not so easily observable
components in this system
the star's luminosity is remarkably high
at 16 times that of the sun
its temperature is estimated at roughly
8 500 kelvin or 8
200 degrees celsius
thermal health could be as old as 400 to
480 million years
according to today's models of stellar
evolution the star may grow to be around
1 billion years old
on reaching this age it will more likely
than not go supernova and turn into a
white dwarf
thermal health a is surrounded by a disc
of protoplanetary gas and dust
divided into several segments its inner
radius is 133 astronomical units with a
width measuring about 25 astronomical
units
this disc is thought to be an active
stellar nursery with celestial bodies
regularly born there
that is why it is an area of keen
interest for astronomers
it used to be thought that there was a
massive planet lurking somewhere in
thermal house environs it was even given
a name dagon
however further observations showed that
there was hardly any planet there after
all
it must have been a wide cloud of dust
that was taken for an exoplanet it would
have originated on collision of
asteroids and comets
0.9 light years away from the main
component of the system there lies fomo
how to be
also known as tw pisces or striny
it's an orange dwarf with a mass around
70 percent that of the sun with its
radius roughly 63 percent that of the
sun
the surface temperature is estimated at
approximately 4700 kelvin which is
4400 degrees celsius
interestingly the star's luminosity is
much lower than that of the sun
our host star is five times brighter
in 2019 on carrying out spectral and
proper motion analysis scientists put
forward a suggestion that there might be
a celestial body as heavy as 0.6 to 1.9
jupiter masses orbiting the star the
existence of this body still remains to
be confirmed and its exact orbits
parameters calculated precisely
at this point preliminary estimations
show that it should take the
hypothetical planet 25 years to complete
a full orbit around its host star
the third star in the thermal howard
system is lp876-10
it is a red dwarf lying two and a half
light years away from the main component
of the system the star is five times
lighter than the sun and its surface
temperature is slightly over
3100 kelvin
it takes lp
876-10 approximately 20 million years to
complete a full orbit around thermal
health a apparently the red dwarf would
have orbited its big brother just 22
times since the birth of the system as
for planets or exoplanet candidates none
of these have so far been detected near
the star
still observations allow us to suppose
that there is a cloud of gas and dust
around it whose radius is anything from
10 to 40 astronomical units
our next and final destination for today
is 37.3 light years away from the earth
that's the distance we would have
covered now to reach arcturus the
brightest star in the northern
hemisphere and the fourth brightest star
in the night sky
the star is the main component of a
binary star system it is an orange giant
whose life is now slowly drawing to a
close
most of its hydrogen has already been
transformed into helium and now the star
is busy burning the remains of its
stellar fuel and gradually expanding in
size
arcturus is also the brightest star of a
great stellar stream named in its honor
this gargantuan structure is in fact the
debris of a dwarf galaxy absorbed by the
milky way some 2 billion years ago
it contains 53 stars
most of them are old and dim and not
nearly as impressive as arcturus
arcturus emits 170 times as much
luminous energy as the sun although its
surface temperature is much lower at
just
4251 kelvin
it is thought that this giant used to be
quite like our sun because its mass is
just 10 percent bigger but what with the
inevitable depletion of its stellar fuel
and the inner pressure of its scorching
hot plasma the star turned into an
orange giant whose radius is now 25
times that of the sun
according to today's theory of stellar
evolution
this is something that our sun is
expected to go through in the distant
future too
arcturus's age is gauged at anything
from six to eight and a half billion
years
it is hard to predict when it will go
supernova at the end of its life cycle
but it will happen quite soon in
astronomical terms
shedding its outer layers arcturus will
become a scorching hot white dwarf
destined to slowly cool off in the
course of billions of years to
follow the second component of the
system is barely visible against the
background of its giant companion
this small star with luminosity 20 times
lower than that of arcturus lies so
close to it that it's hardly possible to
define its parameters
even if some planets did manage to form
in this stellar system many millions of
years ago they must have been absorbed
by arcturus itself
either way no objects have been detected
in the stars environs at this point
having been closely observed by mankind
for hundreds of years
the universe is still a source of
countless mysteries with such
fascinating objects discovered close to
our system what may be lurking further
say hundreds and thousands of light
years away when observing the night sky
humans gaze barely brushes the closest
edge of the great cosmos with its
forbidding mysterious and infinitely
attractive expenses
we're definitely looking to thousands of
amazing new discoveries
meanwhile feel free to hit the like
button subscribe if you still haven't
done so and be on the lookout for more
of our videos let's keep in touch
[Music]
[Applause]
you